bonsoir
voici l'arrivée de jean paul ii à orly
jean paul 2 qui va baiser la terre de
france comme il le fait au début de
chaque voyage
jean paul 2 qui est actuellement en
train de prononcer une homélie très
profonde que je viens d'écouter et où il
vient de dire l'essentiel en fait de
deux tous voyage la haine
l'emportera-t-elle sur l'amour m tu
aimes tu sais la question qu'il est en
train de poser question fondamentale
pour la société pour l'individu dit il
aimes-tu c'est véritablement le cri du
pape
en ce moment nous sommes en direct avec
notre dame où jean paul ii hf2 prononcé
l'homélie pendant la messe sur le parvis
alain ferme bac je souhaite a pris nous
sommes à la fin de l'homélie et je vous
laisse entendre les dernières phrases de
l'allocution paul de son éloquence la
question que le christ adressé aux trois
à pierre m.kim même qu que cette
question résonne et trouvent un écho
profond en chacun de nous l'avenir des
laumes et du monde en dépend écoutez
rond cette question comprendrons-nous
sont importants
comment y répondrons nous voilà le saint
père vient de terminer son homélie vous
l'avez dit roger gicquel il posait la
question aimes tu m'aimes tu pendant
vingt minutes le saint-père ici devant
une foule assez nombreuse vient de
prononcer une mini très émouvante
maintenant dans quelques instants
plusieurs intentions de prières seront
lus ici
la première par un jeune artiste
ensuite une infirmière une institutrice
retraitée
un employé de bureau et aussi
un membre du gouvernement lire à jerez
l'intention de prière
c'est monsieur norbert se garent
l'église la plupart à lisier ou ptt
maintenant le sabé se dresse ou la
protéine l'église de la région
parisienne
s'adressant au diocèse de paris
adieu les aspirations de tous les hommes
nos frères et demandons-lui d'exaucer
les pierres que nous lui adressons aux
normes des jésus son fils bien aimé
voilà maintenant nous allons entendre
peut-être la première intention de
prière particulière elle est prononcée
par une infirmière tient échappe à la
dégradation à laquelle le conduisait le
réduisent des perspectives trop
commercial
voilà je vous rappelle le une phrase
encore de l'homélie en effet très
émouvante que nous venons d'entendre de
jean paul ii
cette lutte pour donner forme à notre
monde semble être plus grande que jamais
et plus d'une fois nous nous demandons
en tremblant si la haine ne l'emportera
pas sur l'amour la guerre sur la paix la
destruction sur la construction et la
jean paul ii fait appel à tous ceux qui
ont des responsabilités dans le monde
pour un peu appliqué ce message ce
message d'amour ce voyage vous le savez
sans doute a été entrepris avec une
heure de retard parce qu'au départ de
rome l'avion d'alitalia déjà en bout de
piste avait un pneu dégonflé il a fallu
du temps pour réparer l'incident
ensuite cette première journée du voyage
du pape a été conforme à ce qui a été
prévu
à une nuance près tout de même si
l'accueil des parisiens était très
chaleureux ces parisiens étaient sans
doute moins nombreux que prévu par
l'épiscopat
on en entend des 500 milles sur les
champs-elysées à la concorde et sur
l'itinéraire jusqu'à notre dame
ça n'a pas été tout à fait le cas mais
ce qu'on sait aussi c'est que les
reportages à la télévision était très
très suivie dans toute la france
actuellement se termine à notre-dame
donc sur le parvis
la grand messe célébrée par jean paul ii
nous venons de le voir et il faut je
crois maintenant revoir en images un
résumé des grandes étapes de ce voyage
avec jackie collins d'abord et puis avec
bernard chevallier
l'été 17h20 quand l'hélicoptère qui
amenait jean paul ii d'orly et dans
lequel a des tripes et à ses cardinaux
marty etchegaray carraso lca rasoli
ainsi que le nonce apostolique aux
seniors kenichi se pose à placer aux
finances au moment où le sperme était le
spectateur les cloches de toutes les
églises de paris ce n'est à la volée
pour saluer son arrivée
accueilli par le président de la
république et madame giscard d'estaing
jean paul ii salué les officiels venue
le recevoir
les cardinaux le premier ministre est
également mort oui messieurs power
chaban delmas monsieur jacques chirac et
la plupart des ministres du gouvernement
après avoir entendu l'hymne pontifical
et la marseillaise jean paul ii prenez
place avec monsieur giscard d'estaing à
bord d'un command car surélevé aménagé
spécialement pour ce voyage
place de la concorde une foule assez
dans cette assemblée le saint-père
s'adressa pour la première fois au
parisien après avoir entendu discours de
bienvenue du président de la république
très fin père le peuple français vous
souhaite la bienvenue sur le sol du pays
qu'une longue tradition désignait comme
la fille aînée de l'église
l'honneur est la grande joie que je
ressens accueillir votre sainteté gento
pays d'où vous venez à ce que vous êtes
et à ce que vous faites
le pays d'où vous venez
comme premier pape slave de l'histoire
la courageuse pologne ami fidèle et
sensible de la france ce que vous êtes
votre simplicité votre humanité votre
foi rayonnante et assuré marc déjà votre
pontificat
est ce que vous faites
essayer de répondre à l'appel qui monte
de tous les peuples du monde vers
davantage de justice vers la paix et
vers le renouveau spirituel de
l'humanité
en venant leur porter le message
d'espoir et de certitudes de l'église
catholique
je souhaite très saint père que vous
aussi vous gardiez longtemps le souvenir
de l'accueil de la france et qu'il vous
apporte un encouragement et un soutien
dans la quête émouvante que vous
conduisez seul en vous même et à la tête
de l'église universelle pour un monde
plus juste plus pacifique et plus doux
pour la souffrance des hommes vivent
jean paul ii
je vous salue très spécialement cher
catholiques de france
mes frères et mes soeurs dans le christ
mes amis vous m'avez invité à constater
qu'un sens en presque après le baptême
des votes relations que la foire est
toujours vivante jeu dynamique que la
générosité ne marque pas c'est vous elle
s'est traduit même par un bouillonnement
d'initiative des recherches des
réflexions il vous faut en effet
affronter des problèmes souvent nouveau
ou tout au moins des problématiques
nouvelles le contexte dans lequel vous
vivez évolue rapidement en fonction des
mutations culturelles et sociales qui ne
sont pas sans influer progressivement
sur le mur sur les mentalités
c'est une multitude d'interrogations qui
se posent à vous que faire comme à
répondre aux besoins fondamentaux de
l'homme contemporain qui révèle
finalement un immense besoin des dieux
retourner aux chrétiens ta dignité
disait le grand pas salon et moi sont un
digne successeur
je vous dis à vous mes frères et soeurs
catholiques de france reconnaissait
votre dignité
soyez fiers de votre foi dit d'ondés
l'esprit que le père vous a fait je
viens parmi vous coût 1 pour avec la
seule richesse des la fois pèlerins de
l'énergie donné à l'église et au monde
l'exemple des votre fidélité sans faille
et de votre zèle missionnaire ma visite
chez vous veut être en même temps car
témoignage de solidarité à l'égard de
vos pasteurs un appel à un élan nouveau
devant les tasses nombreuses qui s'offre
à vous
tant pis le départ pour notre dame avec
à ses côtés le cardinal marty archevêque
de paris
le saint-père emprunter le boulevard
saint germain rifle joyeuse et bon
enfant c'était ça semblait à la rue
dante la rue lagrange le poteau double
face un père arrivé la basilique
pourrait présider le thé des hommes
à notre dame le saint père est accueilli
par monseigneur lecordier lancé l'évêque
de saint denis et doyen du chapitre puis
par l'archiprêtre de la cathédrale
le chanoine emile bérard à l'intérieur
de la basilique notre dame n'avait pris
place le président de la république et
madame giscard d'estaing les membres du
gouvernement les corps constitués des
représentants des partis politiques des
organisations syndicales
une foule très dense des parisiens des
catholiques qui avait tenu à venir
applaudir le saint père est associée à
sa première prière à la vierge
depuis c'est le cardinal marty qui
devait accueillir jean paul 2 à
l'intérieur de cette basilique qui a été
pendant des siècles le témoin de toute
l'histoire glorieuse et de l'histoire
triste des français et plus
particulièrement des parisiens
et
oh
après sans père c'est une oeuvre
historique que nous vivons c'est une
heure deux fois un moment d'intense
émotion
les hautes autorités de notre pays vous
salue la france entière terre de liberté
religieuse et de respect de toutes les
convictions vous accueillent ceux qui ne
partagent pas notre foi chrétienne
savent et beaucoup me l'ont dit que
témoin de l'évangile d'amour vous voulez
être le serviteur des serviteurs de dieu
visiblement ému par ce mot d'accueil
d'une cabine l archevêque de tarifs qui
accueille la première fois jean claude
dans la basilique lettres colis pen
laval jean paul ii devait ensuite réunir
à la prière de tous ceux qui croyant ou
non croyants voulait faire monter un
premier hommage à la vierge à la vierge
de notre dame
c'était le chant du magnificat
et
mais si jean paul ii n'a pas monté à la
tradition dès qu'il arrive dans un pays
sa première démarche première démarche
religieuse et d'aller se recueillir dans
un sanctuaire marial car sa piété envers
la vierge est connu et il tient à mettre
son voyage sur la protection de celles
qui est évoqué en france sous le nom de
notre dame de paris
oui jean paul 2 n'a pas oublié les non
catholiques dans ses prières
il a salué aussi les communautés
judaïque et islamique
mais dans le concert d'entousiasme qui
salue l'arrivée du pape en france il ya
tout de même une note différente c'est
celle de la fédération de la libre
pensée qui a tenu aujourd'hui une
conférence de presse avec la
participation de plusieurs organisations
philosophiques philosophique et laïcs
comme la ligue des droits de l'homme les
francs maçons du grand orient de france
le comité national d'action laïque entre
autres et qui conteste la caution
apportée par l'état français à cette
visite du chef d'une communauté
spirituelle notre entretien
j'accueille contre quoi nous nous
élevons avec force c'est contre l'appui
moral et matériel apporté par les
pouvoirs publics français
l'état français est là présent la
république en tête à cette entreprise
dans une république qui d'une part se
dit encore laïque par l'article 1er de
la constitution et qui d'autre part n'a
pas abrogé que je sache la loi de
séparation des églises et de l'état loi
de séparation des xvie et à qui précise
de façon très nette dans son article 1
que la république subventionne et ne
salarie non seulement aux calculs mais
aucune manifestation religieuse chili a
donc pas un viol manifeste de la loi de
séparation
à bruxelles la nuit a porté conseil aux
ministres de la communauté européenne
après 18h dur de négociations ils ont
réussi à organiser le miracle du
sauvetage de l'europe verte un compromis
qui est un succès pour madame thatcher
tout le monde le dit un compromis qui
est satisfaisant pour la france selon le
ministre de l'agriculture mais un
compromis vivement critiqué par le rpr
qui parle de gâchis européen et de
concessions exorbitantes faite par la
france
ce compromis signés par les ministres à
bruxelles devaient être ensuite ratifié
par chaque gouvernement la france y est
prête à condition que le premier
ministre britannique donne d'abord son
accord et on pense qu'elle ne donnera
mais elle se donne semble-t-il un
week-end de réflexion
alors voyons d'abord sur quoi portent le
compromis de cette pluie de problème
était lié je vous le rappelle madame
thatcher voulait d'abord qu'on réduise
la contribution briques
nico budget européen avant d'accepter
l'augmentation de 5% des prix agricoles
déjà signé par cbi père tonnerre et elle
a en effet obtenu la réduction de sa
participation au budget pour deux ans et
même peut-être pour 3 voyons ce qu'il en
est et voyons aussi les conséquences de
tout cela pour les agriculteurs français
mais aussi pour tous les français
contribuables jean françois robinet oui
il faut souligner en effet l'importance
économique des longues négociations qui
sautent sont déroulés à bruxelles
il s'agissait vous l'avez dit de très
grosses sommes d'argent le budget
communautaire dont on parlait et 2,84
milliards de francs et ils financent
tout le fonctionnement du marché commun
les aides au développement par exemple
concerne les régions dans leur ensemble
est bien sûr plus spécialement
l'équipement de l'agriculture et le
soutien des prix agricoles c'est un
système qui permet l'approvisionnement
des neuf pays indépendant le moins
possible de l'extérieur c'est là le
noeud du problème car les anglais eux
voyez plutôt un marché commun très
ouvert leur permettant notamment de
continuer à importer des moutons et du
beurre bon marché de nouvelle zélande
mais les anglais ont tout de même
accepté et c'est l'un des points
importants du compromis
un règlement du marché du mouton grâce
un système de stockage et de primes
les éleveurs français devraient avoir un
prix minimum garanti de 20 francs 17 le
kg d'agneau l'angleterre va devoir pour
sa part et comme ses partenaires signé
avec la nouvelle zélande un accord
limitant strictement les achats de
moutons à ce pays les autres points
essentiels de l'accord rapidement il
s'agit de l'assurance pour les
viticulteurs de vendre un certain prix
leurs 20 stocké depuis la récolte
précédente
et il y en a beaucoup pour les éleveurs
de viande une prime à la vache
allaitante 230 francs par vache élevant
son veau ce qui va diminuer les
livraisons de lait et puis surtout la
hausse générale des prix agricole +5 %
en écu pour tout le monde
5 % auxquels s'ajoutent les ajustements
monétaires pour la france le relèvement
moyen est de 10%
cependant les producteurs de lait
devront payer une taxe de 2% au lieu de
0 et demi pour cent actuellement pour
aider à l'écoulement des excédents
ces mesures très résumé sont donc liées
à l'accord presque probable maintenant
on peut dire plus que probable des neuf
chefs d'état et de gouvernement au cas
où il y aurait un blocage par exemple
encore du côté des anglais on ne sait
jamais le conseil des ministres a pris
acte ce matin l'elysée des mesures
nationales que le gouvernement
appliquerait pour assurer le main
du revenu des agriculteurs ces mesures
ne seront publiés que si cela est
nécessaire
les ors déjà débordés d'ores et déjà par
dont il faut assurer que d'autres
mesures qui étaient attendus ont été
prises
on les trouve à l'intérieur d'un plan de
développement de l'élevage pour la
viande sur lequel nous aurons l'occasion
de revenir prochaine alors sur ses
décisions de bruxelles il est
intéressant de dès maintenant de savoir
ce que l'on pense à londres avant de
connaître la décision de madame thatcher
jean-louis burgat notre correspondant
permanent à londres a grignoté un petit
bout de plus de la miche de pain
communautaire le titre de l' evening
standard donne le ton de la réaction
populaire ce soir à l'ombre pas de
triomphalisme mais l'on estime que la
fermeté de margaret sature enfin porter
ses fruits c'est l'offre la meilleure
que l'on nous ait fait à présent
commente un autre journal les six
personnes réaffirme clairement le
sentiment général ici c'est grande
bretagne s'apprête à dire oui à l'accord
mise au point par les neuf ce raid il ne
faut pas attendre une réponse officielle
avant lundi à qom sature s'est enfermé
tout à l'heure avec son homme de
confiance le ministre des affaires
étrangères lord carrington dans sa
résidence d'été curse elle le voit qui
passait le week-end pour étudier point
par point un texte de bruxelles de plus
le parlement est en congé jusqu'au début
du mois prochain en grande-bretagne le
premier ministre s'explique d'abord
devant les députés
il est difficile cependant d'imaginer un
nouveau refus de la dame de fer
le cas échéant cela ne pourrait que
signifier sa décision de voir son pays
s'installait dans une demi retraite face
aux institutions de la communauté ou une
politique avait été pratiquée par une
quinzaine d'années en tout cas du
ministère estimait ce matin du site que
des progrès substantiels ont été
accomplis à bruxelles
c'est la première fois depuis le triste
sommet du place entendent le regard et
enfin londres
en effet il ya du progrès alors
maintenant comment les agriculteurs
français juge-t-il cet accord de
bruxelles il est un peu tôt pour
l'apprécier dans l'ensemble mais en tout
cas des représentants de leur tout
premier syndicat la fnsea
le représentant françois guillaume est
satisfait même s'il juge qu'il ya encore
à faire pour maintenir le revenu des
agriculteurs français écouter françois
liot écouter sur le principe d'un accord
entre les neuf il est évident que
lorsqu'on est favorable à la
construction européenne on ne peut être
que content de voir que on a trouvé
enfin tout du moins dans l'attenté d'une
réponse définitive des anglais un accord
semble être trouvé alors le problème est
de voir maintenant le contenu de cet
accord
les augmentations de prix qui sont
proposés doivent être examinées en
fonction du point de départ et grâce à
la pression syndicale compte exercer
tous les producteurs européens tous les
agriculteurs européens est évident que
nous avons obtenu une
mange plus large mais cette cette
décision sur les prix s'est
éventuellement décision pour les prix il
faut aussi l'examiner en fonction du
contexte économique et comparer cette
augmentation à l'évolution des coût de
production et notamment du taux
d'inflation
redoutant que ce taux d'inflation ne
soit élevé
nous avons en ce qui nous concerne nous
sur le plan français pris un certain
nombre de précautions et obtenu
l'engagement du président de la
république
d'une part de compenser la perte
enregistrée par les éleveurs
entre le 1er avril et le 1er juin date
possible de l'entrée en vigueur de
l'accord en question est par ailleurs
obtenu l'engagement également que le
pouvoir d'achat des agriculteurs
seraient maintenues au cours de l'année
1981 tous les parisiens n'étaient pas
sur le trajet du pape jean paul ii cet
après midi on vous l'a déjà laissé
entendre mais en tout cas il y avait 25
mille parisien qui préférait idolâtré le
tennis à roland garros roland garros où
l'un des dieux du stade était
aujourd'hui le français noah
victorieux du jeune américain tels cher
en 16e de finale de finale tel cher et
pas thatcher le prochain adversaire de
nova sera l'américain connor ce
troisième joueur mondial après demain
connors qui a battu avant-hier un autre
français caujolle au terme d'un match
dramatique car caujolle aurait pu gagner
noah vengera t-il caujolle c'est toute
la question connors en tout cas lui
s'est débarrassé mais sans brio excessif
de l'italien bulgari
daniel pautrat
balle de match l'instant est important
noah et el cheikh joue de fait une heure
et 44 minutes
le français a gagné les deux premiers
sets 6-3 6-0 et les deux joueurs sont à
égalité 6 6 dans le troisième
c'est le fameux tie break le point
décisif pendant ce temps deux autres
français ont été battus en cinq sets par
deux américain joe kennedy et taïwan les
deux français battu casa et denis
naegelen
il reste donc porte qui sera opposé à
bord guy roger aymard à demain et puis
ce sont les deux derniers qualifiés
penser avec yannick noah qui vous le
voyez se qualifie donc en battant l
chimicolor c'est troisième joueur du
monde c'est un très bon joueur
cela dit je pense que sur terre battue
il est un peu du jouable et j'espère que
j'espère que
demain
et à vous après demain je serai en bonne
forme car je pense que sur cette surface
devant mon public je peut l'inquiéter
et vous avez vu donc jouer jimmy connors
ce contre caujolle qu'est ce qu'elle
vous qu'avez vous pensé de ce match et
de la réaction du public
yannick noah je trouve un peu
regrettable que devant son public un
joueur se fasse siffler jean-françois
était tout près de l'exploit je pense
qu'avec l'aide du public ils auraient pu
l'emporter
le public a préféré connor c'est un peu
regrettable et le public a retrouvé
jimmy connors ce cet après-midi
l'adversaire de noah dimanche le numéro
trois mondial avec ça tu est ronde et
ses yeux rieurs qu'au nord sen a eu
beaucoup de chance d'éliminer caujolle
avant-hier et beaucoup de mal à se
dévore 7-5 6-4 7-5 mais il s'est
qualifié lui alors que victor catchy le
finaliste de l'année dernière est
éliminée lui par le chilien rage
et puis en ce moment se discute toujours
le match entre john mcenroe et
l'australien mcnamee mcenroe troisième
mondial mcnamee 49e joueur seulement et
il y a eu des contestations des
discussions comme depuis le début de la
semaine à roland garros il ya plus de
quatre heures que les deux hommes sont
sur le terrain pour le moment mcnamee a
gagné 2,7 mcenroe un seul et il mène 6-5
dans la quatrième manche
le championnat du monde de formule 1 est
il compromis c'est la question que l'on
se pose ce soir après les essais du
grand prix d'espagne auquel trois grands
constructeurs et non des moindres
renault ferrari et alfa romeo + le petit
constructeur osella ont refusé de
participer
en effet le conflit s'envenime entre la
fédération internet du internationale du
sport automobile et l'association des
constructeurs de formule 1 dont ligier
fait partie mais par nous
la fédération sportive veut d'imposer de
nouvelles règles dans la compétition que
les constructeurs avaient accepte mal et
le conflit d'aujourd'hui n'est que le
résultat finalement d'une véritable
guerre entre les petits constructeurs et
les grands qui voient eux dans la
formule 1 une occasion exceptionnelle de
promotion pour leur marque
le grand prix d'espagne ne pourra
certainement pas compter pour le
classement au championnat du monde
dommage pour la fit et pironi qui ont
largement dominé la première séance
d'essais sur les ligier devant les deux
williams de rotman et jones un autre
français alain prost est 6e
c'est bien mais ce qui importe
maintenant c'est de savoir si le
championnat de formule 1 est en train de
perdre tout son sens aujourd'hui en
espagne alors sur ce point
correspondance de josé rosinski le
championnat du monde de formule 1 a
éclaté ce matin sur la piste de germain
il est vrai qu'un revers dans le filet
entre la fédération internationale et
l'association des constructeurs de
formule 1 s'est transformée en guerre
ouverte et d'allumer à l'occasion d'un
incident de procédure mais personne
n'est dupe réaliser l'objet du litige et
l'exercice du pouvoir sur la précieuse
et fructueuse formule 1 dont les
constructeurs qui étaient peuple
apparaît et que la fédération fait force
de récupérer la nous et tendez des
constructeurs en révolte et qui
constituent les trois quarts des
effectifs pourraient encore être santé
organisé vendredi aux championnats de
pirates mais représenterait une
compétition privé de renault ferrari et
alfa romeo la sainte alliance des
grandes marques qui a choisi le camp de
la légitimité lui donneront sans doute
une idée car tous les autres sports
toujours tout d'abord un rappel c'est ce
soir qu'ont lieu les matchs aller des
demi finales de la coupe de france de
football à monaco l'as monaco contre
montpellier la paillade et à orléans
orléans contre le paris football club
le giro est bien une très bonne nouvelle
il nous a frappé un grand coup il a
remporté la 14e étape une étape de
montagne de 186 km il a repris 42
secondes à sarni une 36 à moser
changement de leader au classement
général le maillot rose maintenant pour
l'italien panizza et 2e i know à une
minute 5 seulement à saint-sébastien au
pays basque espagnol des inconnus sans
doute membres de l' eta ont mitraillé
plusieurs voitures de police et gardes
civils ont été grièvement blessées
depuis le début de l'année 60 personnes
dont 27 policiers ou militaires ont
trouvé la mort dans les attentats en
espagne
quatre ans après les sanglants et
sanglantes émeutes de soweto qui avait
fait 600 morts
l'afrique du sud est de nouveau emporté
dans un tourbillon de grèves de
manifestations c'est de protestation
contre la politique d'apartheid
c'est-à-dire de ségrégation raciale
hier des centaines de personnes ont été
arrêtées mercredi deux jeunes métis ont
été faits par la police dans cette ville
où ont lieu les manifestations que vous
voyez cette contestation politique
s'ajoute d'ailleurs en ce moment de très
graves conflits sociaux les menaces de
crise gouvernemental se précise
actuellement en israël le parti
démocrate refuse toujours le remaniement
ministériel proposé par le premier
ministre puisqu'on ne veut pas monsieur
shamir monsieur begin se déclare prêt à
assurer lui-même les fonctions de
ministre de la défense poste dont
monsieur weidmann a des messieurs selon
un sondage publié dans l'express qui
paraît demain 72% des français pensent
qu'une nouvelle guerre et possibles 64%
que l'armement nucléaire est
indispensable pour la france et 62 %
croit à l'efficacité de la dissuasion de
notre force de frappe
hold up sanglant rue lafayette à paris
en fin de matinée quatre gangsters qui
venaient de dévaliser une succursale de
la bnp se retrouver face à face avec des
gardiens de la paix au moment où il
s'enfuyait
tout le monde a tiré une véritable
fusillade un policier et un employé de
la banque ont été blessés à des
gangsters à jeune homme d'une trentaine
d'années tué les trois autres parmi
lesquels une jeune femme ont été arrêtés
mais on ignore pour l'instant leur
identité la fédération nationale des
coopératives de consommateurs propose
elle que la mention conventionné ou bien
la mention non conventionnés soit
clairement inscrit tous affichés sur les
portes des cabinets médicaux afin que
les malades ou les clients comme vous
préférez sache à quelle sauce ils seront
mangés ou plutôt à quel prix quel prix
il risque deux pays enfin je vous
signale que des morceaux de la fusée
ariane ont été retrouvés au large de la
guyane hier quelques tôles du lanceur et
des rétrofusées les débris très utiles
puisqu'ils vont permettre de mieux
circonscrire la zone d'impact est
facilité à 6 de nouvelles recherches
le temps est bien en toutes régions les
températures ont été assez basse
aujourd'hui le plus souvent inférieure à
15 degrés cela fait 5 degrés tout de
même en dessous des températures
habituelles de fin mai seule la côte
méditerranéenne et celles du sud
west bénéficier de températures voisines
de 20 degrés plus normal le temps demain
de la bretagne et de la normandie aux
pyrénées temps couvert le matin avec
quelques pluies éparses dans la journée
sur le centre le nord est et l'est après
une matinée fraîche et des éclaircies le
ciel se couvrira à nouveau il y aura des
ondes et partout ailleurs ciel variable
avec éclaircies
les vents d'ouest seront modérés des
températures plutôt en hausse
voilà nous allons tourner maintenant sur
le parvis de notre-dame où le pape
achève la messe et en direct maintenant
à la ferme
oui la chaîne la messe va s'achever dans
quelques instants
bon moment c'est la communion aussitôt
après cette messe le pape se retrouvera
de temps notre dame lui rencontrera les
prêtres avant de se rendre à l'hôtel de
ville tout à l'heure je vous disais
plusieurs intentions de prière ont été
lus je retiendrai une intention celle
qui a été lu par un membre du
gouvernement par monsieur d'horreur se
garent ce que tel état aux ptt
voici une des phrases qu'il a prononcées
je prie pour que les autorités
politiques n'entrave pas l'annnonce du
message du christ et pour terminer une
remarque qui n'est pas une critique mais
un regret qui fait écho à votre
constatations du tanneur gicquel un
regret sans doutes exprimés par beaucoup
de parisiens car à la concorde comme ici
il y avait certes du monde mais sans
doute pas autant que prévu et je crois
que le principal responsable et bien si
la dissuasion exercée par tous les
services d'ordre et surtout par les
services d'ordre des scouts des
religieux de ceux de l'épiscopat
français ainsi notre dame autour du
podium en ce moment même il y encore
beaucoup de place et pourtant des
milliers de parisiens sont retenus au
delà des ponts par des barrières
car il n'avait pas l'invitation c'est
dommage vraiment dommage certes les
mesures de sécurité sont tout à fait
indispensables mais de là à prendre le
pas sur des événements
heureux mais peut-être que la leçon
aujourd'hui servira et que tout sera
réparé dans les jours à venir
en voyant ce moment le saint père vient
de guinée et la communion aux autorités
qui assistèrent de trimestre et les
volumes allant jusqu'à destin malabar et
le président pères voilà ici le parvis
de notre-dame où malgré quelques
barrières trop rigide des milliers de
parisiens sont qu'une même rassemblé
devant le podium où le pape vient de
concélébrer une mère avec les prêtres et
les évêques de la région parisienne
avoue roger gicquel merci alain ferme
bac et dois je me permets de vous dire
que je trouve votre réflexion sur les
barrages devant le pape tout à fait
pertinente tout à l'heure jean paul ii
va se rendre à l'hôtel de ville
jacques chirac l'accueillera en disant
que jean paul ii est un témoin de la
conscience et de l'esprit
pour ceux qui croient comme pour ceux
qui ne croient pas à 23h dans notre
édition de 23 heures vous aurez de
larges extraits des cérémonies
maintenant qui vont suivre notamment
donc à l'hôtel de ville et puis demain
rendez vous à 9h 50 si vous le voulez
bien toujours sur tf1 en direct de
l'elysée cette fois pour la réception la
grande réception en l'honneur du pape à
l'elysée où seront la représenter toutes
les personnalités de tous les partis
politiques français
voilà merci de votre attention merci
d'avoir écouté ce journal au nom de
toute l'équipe de tf1 qualité qui a je
vous l'assuré beaucoup travaillé
aujourd'hui pour vous bonne soirée à
tous et à toutes